Hey Thoughty2 here.
Ah, the Koala bear, such adorable little balls
of fluffy stupidity.
Don't let its suave looks and longing beady
eyes fool you into thinking that it's up to
something.
There really is, absolutely nothing, going
on in there.
Scientists have discovered that the beloved
koala bear may be the least intelligent mammal
on the planet.
Don't believe me?
Look!
This one's trying to climb a bloody painting.
"Oh you guys saw that did you".
They may have large fluffy heads, but a koala
brain is tiny, making up just 2% of its body
weight, the smallest brain to body-size ratio
of any mammal.
They also have a smooth brain which is evolutionary
language for "they're about a million years
late to the party".
Koalas are so stupid that if you take a few
eucalyptus leaves and put them on a plate
in front of a koala it won't eat them.
Because it thinks that if it's not attached
to a tree then it can't possibly be food.
But not only are they stupid, koala bears
generally make terrible animals, they're just
put together all wrong.
Their favourite food is so inadequate that
they have to move really slowly to preserve
energy.
Eucalyptus leaves are ridiculously low in
nutrients and calories, they need to eat 2,000
leaves a day to survive.
It's like us humans living entirely off celery,
okay your friend at work may have tried that
diet for a month, but eventually it's gonna
end badly -
Eucalyptus truly is a terrible food.
It's not even food, eucalyptus leaves do everything
they can to make it perfectly clear that they
do not want to be eaten.
Not only are they practically inedible, they're
chewier and tougher than your grandma's pork
chops.
But they are also poisonous.
But koalas were like "listen boys, we've got
this" and dedicated their entire evolutionary
history to adapting themselves to be able
to digest this toxic plant and not dying afterwards.
When they could have eaten literally any other
food and done considerably better at being
animals.
They get so little energy in fact that they
need to sleep 18 hours a day.
But they're too darn intellectually-deficient
to find another food to eat.
Eucalyptus is so difficult to digest that
it takes four whole days and only adult koalas
have sufficiently developed digestive systems
to cope with it.
Baby koalas can't digest the leaves at all,
so they eat their own mother's feces, known
as "fecal pap" to survive.
Not only that, but they use their claws to
scrape the poop dinner out their mother's
anus.
They may look docile but get on the wrong
side of these moronic poop-eating furballs
and you'll regret it, in fights they go full-psycho.
Yet, despite their occasional hissy fit, the
koala bear has been named by one animal conservationist
as "the most boring of all animals".
Poor little guys.
And if after all that, you still need more
proof that koalas really are the most pathetic
and unfortunate animal - about 90% of all
koalas have chlamydia, which makes them incontinent,
so they spend all day pissing themselves.
And if you thought this cuddly little misfit
couldn't get any weirder... this is what they
sound like.
Yeah.. thanks for watching.